less than eight years since the first
referendum we have a date for the second
the 19th of october next year could see
scots return to the polls
and while westminster continues to
oppose it
the first minister is pushing ahead
scotland over generations has paid a
price for not being independent
westminster governments we don't vote
for
imposing policies we don't support
too often holding us back from
fulfilling our potential
that reality has really been starker
than it is now
opposition leaders accuse the smp of
having a selfish obsession with
independence we won't play nicholas
sturgeon's games we won't take part in a
pretend poll when there is real work to
be done
real work on the global cost of living
crisis real work to invest in public
services real work to rebuild our
economy
the question put to the scottish people
would be the same as 2014 should
scotland be an independent country but
there's no certainty at the moment that
the referendum will even happen
holding a second independence referendum
is shrouded in legal problems the
scottish government has already referred
the plan to the supreme court if and
it's a big if they actually allow it
there's no agreement from westminster to
act on the result
there's no court there's no law that can
force the united kingdom to break itself
up ultimately it can only be done if the
national government of westminster
thinks reluctantly but thinks that the
sufficient opinion in scotland that
wants to become independent nicola
sturgeon says her government has a clear
mandate to deliver this vote but amid
legal uncertainty they're a mix if
independence does come
i've already explained to my family i
will move south because scotland should
be part of great britain
not an independent country any um
negotiations to disband a 300-year old
union is going to take some considerable
time people scotland voted for
the current government that was they
round on the mandate of a second
independence referendum and in terms of
i would vote for it i need to see what
the
economic impacts are how it's all laid
out
a test for the union that was billed as
a once-in-a-generation vote could be set
to happen twice
in less than a decade
dan whitehead sky news
in edinburgh